hello everyone I hope everybody can hear
me property and well please let me know
if the sound is bad or the image is bad
I'm kind of alone today I don't have my
son with me we had a great time in
Buenos Aires we came back I came back a
couple days yesterday and but unns he
stayed in Buenos Aires he's gonna be
there for maybe a couple months and he's
gonna be doing some programming over
there he needed some space some time to
do his things he's probably gonna join
us every now and then and so during that
time next couple months or until further
notice
we want to have only a couple of days
where we are going to be doing
transmissions that's gonna be Sundays
and Wednesdays same time 9 o'clock
Langford time what is it I think it's
1900 hours a world time whatever it's
called so you know until further notice
we're gonna have only twice a week
because we're really behind we got a lot
of work to do lots of videos articles
writing a book also there's just too
much on our plate aside from other
things that forced us to cut down our
transmission time and on the one hand
it's not such a bad idea to do that
because it gives people time to absorb
the material discuss it for a couple
days rather than go from one subject to
the other from day to day so just keep
that in mind
Shambo and Dave are still there I think
they're still in Chile stuck somewhere
up at IU so chilly and
I hope they're doing fine we had a great
time with them had a couple of reunions
meetings discussions whatever we want to
call them with beer and pizza and
empanadas so I think we did pretty well
down there we I think yeah we had a good
time and of course we didn't only
discuss the subject matter that I
covered during the presentations which
was physics
they're quite interested in this
extinction issue or we can say that
they're interested in economics okay and
extinction as far as I'm concerned at
least as part of that so we did this had
a chance to discuss a lot of this down
there I'm sure you we didn't cover the
the subject completely but we did
exchange ideas and I think we understand
a little better where each of us is
coming from okay and that subject matter
may be for another presentation another
lecture whatever anyways so what do we
cover down there
well I covered three subjects I put one
of the videos up only on the first
subject the other two are coming but
originally I was playing I'm doing
polarization polarization is a
phenomenon we've noticed with light and
I wanted to discuss that but when I got
to that point I said well no before I
discuss that I need to really discuss
the slit experiment and so let me check
to see if everyone's doing fine here
first here before I continue okay
so if if there's any problem with the
transmission please let me know in the
comment section okay anyways I was
planning on covering polarization and I
really move realized that I needed to
cover the slit experiment before I did
that and then when I covered the slicks
better I realized I had to cover physics
itself just give the groundwork for you
know what is visit what is a physical
interpretation and and so that's the way
it went I started with the physical
interpretation what is a physical
interpretation you'll see that video
which is up there already it's uploaded
it and then I followed that with a slit
experiment and finally ended up with
polarization that's how it went and
obviously there were a lot of questions
and that's one of the reasons and I knew
that was gonna happen so one of the
reasons that I held off on the articles
of writing the articles I did or write
the articles but I didn't finish them
because I waited for some feedback and I
did get some feedback and that compels
me to modify the articles to address
some of those issues questions people
have and so that's the way it went what
did I cover in here by the way here's
our little logo or little law commercial
for the rational scientific method
rational physics conference in Buenos
Aires I think we're gonna be doing the
next one somewhere in Sweden us there's
a fellow who has offered to do this in
Sweden who know to organize it and if he
does you know obviously will help a man
will will go down there and get it done
so the next one will probably be in
Sweden it will probably be in summer
sometime or spring maybe I don't know I
would think maybe June July August
something like that so just keep you
know if you're interested just keep that
in mind now anyways uh so what did we do
we had to cover what is a physical
interpretation and for this
you need to think in these terms that
you can't do physics without an object
and so that's that's like the first step
if if you think you can do physics
without an object well then you know
there's there's nothing and that we can
have in common because whatever comes
next is irrelevant
so there is there's this principle that
a rational human being as I call them
accepts and that's that you must have a
physical object in order to do physics
ok some people accept that ok and most
people are we think would accept that
but then we have a problem with the next
step and that's what is a physical
object and I had a great discussion with
another fellow who was quite interested
in physics and he's my brother
one of my brothers and I was stunned by
his answer and so I thought I'd cover
that here because I'm gonna be addressed
I have to address that in my article I
have to revise it to cover that base and
that's he said that a physical object is
that which you can measure now I had
heard you know mass volume you know that
which has mass that which has volume
that which moves but that which you can
touch that which you can see etc etc but
this was the first time that someone
said no that's an object's that which
you can measure so I got a problem with
that
and it just stunned me that that he
would insist on that and so I'm saying
you know here you have a lion or let's
let's put a horse probably easier the
corp gallops right and the horse covers
distance yeah it runs one kilometer one
mile whatever okay so the measurement is
the distance is how much the horse ran
or how much time you can seem to run one
mile or whatever that's the
how much weight the the horse has or how
much mass that kind of thing
or how much energy you use how much
force he used to push his body with his
legs I don't know you know those are
measurements so we measure and we're
saying that the measurement is a
physical object hopefully not hopefully
the horse is the physical object and
he's a physical object before we measure
what he did and the physical object is
not the horse plus the distance he
covered the horse is the object not
horse plus distance horse plus distance
is not an object like you know moving
boy is not knob J boy is an object
moving boy is not an object it's a movie
and but I could convince some of that he
insisted that measurement is what an
object is that which you can measure and
so you know I need to cover that in in a
little bit of D - I have to modify my
article only because of this input which
was unexpected for me and I think what
people do they try to protect their
religion by putting some of these
definitions that are convenient for them
of course they throw that at me and say
well the one you're using is convenient
for you well I'm trying to be objective
I'm not trying to protect the religion
I'm trying to say that you know in order
to do physics in a rational way you must
have an object and then objects that
which has shape and an object is a
standalone object and you know if
there's nothing else in the universe and
there's a table there well that's an
object you don't have to see the table
move because movement would require you
know comparison against something else
another object and here you only have
one object measurement same thing you
know if you're gonna measure measure
with respect to what to a tape to a
scale against what are you gonna measure
you got to measure it against something
else you have to have some kind of
standard okay in order to measure
something and so again you know
the table does not need to move or do
anything for it to be an object and of
course it's got to be a standalone
object you can't have a field as an
object because the field is not a
standalone thing right thing it required
a magnetic field for example we we can't
see the magnetic field without the
magnet you can't have a gravitational
field without you know the Sun or the
earth or some other object so again it's
gotta be a standalone thing and and I
don't think there's any measurement
involved and part of it is has to do
with the fact that measurement itself is
motion and as I said to my brother I
said you know hopefully an object or you
have to define object before you define
motion and if measuring you know
stretching out the tape whatever you do
or timing or whatever you you do however
you measure something requires motion
measurement requires something to move
whether it's the Rope unrolling the tape
running the clock pressing down on the
scale whatever you do or counting you
know atoms because that's also you know
mass you could say the quantity of
matter well you got to be counting all
these atoms right and so all of it
involves motion and I think that's where
the definition of measurement fails
those are some of the ideas I've put
forth and I just got them thinking but
not conceding so get ready for for some
of the things that people say out there
obviously of mathematicians always gonna
say measurement because he likes that he
he wants to put a unit time seconds you
know wait he wants to put kilograms in
there mass of saying kilograms or number
of atoms he wants to put a some kind of
unit in there and and so if you take
that away from him you kill his this
whole argument is whole religion and
that's why they're gonna fight till the
end for measurement anyways we need to
have an object to do physics we need to
define what we mean by an object and the
first realization
for those who have done a little bit of
research on this you can do it starting
today you'll find that no one in the
last 10,000 years has defined what an
object is for the purposes of science
for the purposes of physics and this is
stunning because if our first principle
holds and we say you can't do physics
without an object you would think that
in 10,000 years someone would have
realized this and said hold it you know
let's define what an object is and no
one's ever you even realize the
importance of defining what an object is
for the purposes of physics more so in
the last 400 years since the alleged you
know Scientific Revolution of the that
started in the 17th century days of
Galileo Newton and Huygens and all these
other people so so the issue here is
that you know no one has realized that
and that shows you the state of physics
today if no one has obviously no one
cares about physical objects and I'm not
only talking about people the 20th
century which obviously have forgotten
about objects altogether they're doing
concepts completely you know 100 percent
concepts but I'm talking about people
who seem to care or look for causes and
mechanism people like Michael Faraday
people like Austin Fred F Grinnell in
France you know these people wanted to
get to the bottom of they said what is
it that's moving in it what is this
light thing what is this magnetic thing
that's between two magnets what is
electricity they wanted to know what's
and you know that that got lost with
quantum nobody worries about the what's
anymore nobody know cares about what
what gravity is anymore and they can
live with space-time you know yet the
word time in there which is a concept
they don't care they did they just bend
it and so we have a problem with that
because we have lost touch with physical
objects we don't use physical objects
that do physics and I'm talking about
the mathematical establishment but you
know you
why the people who did care about
finding causes and mechanism people like
you know Faraday and I now and Huygens
and so on all these people they did
realize that you need some kind of
object Newton himself said finger known
hypothesis
I have no hypothesis he did ponder these
issues he did he did wonder you know how
does gravity actually what is the
mechanism
he had the equation no doubt about that
you know he had the relations but he
said what is doing this so how is the
earth being pulled towards the towards
the Sun how is the moon pulled towards
the earth and he realized you know that
the equation was correct but he had no
mechanism for that and that's why he
said that I have no hypothesis but at
least he was conscious that there that
you know this had to be studied and
looked into and today you know we've
lost that completely anyways for a
physical interpretation you need a
physical object you cannot do physical
physical and I'll emphasize physical you
cannot do physical interpretations with
concepts you guys say you're gonna move
love around or information you know
transfer information or kick you know
love war grace or intelligence you can't
do physics by moving concepts and that's
the bottom line so once we define the
word object as that which has shape now
we have something that we can use in
physics and in science right in general
and one of those is the fact that you
know again if you're gonna be do trying
to give a physical interpretation to the
things such as gravity or magnetism you
got to put a little object in there and
yes if you just talk about measurement
or for that matter you know that which
you can touch or see or mass or that
which moves or volume well you know then
then you're dealing with concepts but if
you got to put an object there you say
what object am I gonna put in there well
that's where you
to use your imagination and see what you
can put in all these instances that
makes the universe work and you can't
put particle and you can't put waves and
the reason for that you know the main
reason number one reason okay is that
you cannot produce attraction the force
of pull with particles or waves and the
reason for that is that you know these
are one-way mechanisms particles go
outwards waves go outwards
only in one direction and that's why you
can't use these you cannot try to do
light like maybe you can get away with
particles if you say okay just goes out
fine okay maybe you get away with doing
simulating light with one-way mechanisms
but but you certainly cannot do pool you
cannot do gravity with one-way
mechanisms you need some kind of two
ways
agent in there and so yeah this is where
this is where mathematical physics runs
into trouble and that's where they put
concepts instead of objects so okay so
that's what the first presentation was
about about physical interpretations you
need in order to do physical
interpretation you need a physical
object and an object cannot be
measurement as my dear brother said no
it's got to be something which has shape
and what are we saying here you're
saying I'm saying that you got to make
the invisible visible you know and again
I when I blow a piece of paper you don't
see the air but hopefully when I give
the explanation so what moved the paper
I you know make the invisible the air in
there I'll make it visible for you so
that you can understand my theory what
moved the paper and we got to do exactly
the same thing when we look at gravity
when we look at electricity when we look
at magnetism the functioning of an atom
all of these things have to be mediated
by some physical object and all you have
to do if it's an object that would shape
all you have to do is make it visible
very simple and
of course mathematicians are not used to
doing that because they would like to
they just like to describe and say look
this is what we measure this is the
value that I get so many so many seconds
or so many kilograms or so many meters
whatever and that's why they got into
doing only concepts okay so when I
finished that I moved on to the slit
experiment which was the second part of
my present law or the second
presentation he actually all these were
somewhat separate they relied a little
bit one on each other one was a
prerequisite for the nature for the
following slit experiment what was the
slit experiment slit experiment says
that well let's let me put something up
here again we can't do it with one-way
mechanisms that's the first one that I
want to make clear and here you have one
wave mechanisms you got a stream of
particles and you have the plain
transverse electromagnetic waves
whatever waves are but let's assume
they're a physical object those little
arrows there that you see those are
really vectors they have magnitude and
direction that's what the arrow stands
for it's not a physical arrow
it's a each one of those arrows is a
pictorial representation of magnitude
and direction that's all it is and as
you can see they're all 90 degrees to
the flow and that's why it's called a
transverse wave because the vectors for
these the magnitudes and increasing and
decreasing you know this wavy thing
that's in there is essentially moving or
extending or I guess it's moving
perpendicular to the you know flow of
light okay so what's the problem both of
them are as you can see our one-way
mechanism to the stream of particles in
this case are moving to my right and the
electromagnetic wave is also moving to
the right the idea here is that the
these the weather particles are way
they have origin in the atom okay so
they move outwards they can only move
upwards and obviously they receive from
other atoms but it's another set of
particles on another set of ways it's
not the same way that's leaving okay so
waves you know there it's only one wave
mechanisms okay so what's the issue here
the issue is that here's we have the
slit experiment with particles and the
way they typically illustrate the theory
is that the particle bounces off the
edge of the slit okay we'll call it the
window to make it simple so we have the
window of the slit right and the
particle hits there and goes inwards and
interferes with particles coming from
the other slit so they bounced when the
two particles meet if they're in phase
whatever that could mean in in terms of
particles you have a bright man and
wherever they're off buying half a wave
I don't know how you can interpret that
particle in terms of particles but let's
assume you could if they're off by 1/2
diameter the radius is is slightly off
whatever I don't know how you know maybe
the tennis ball one tennis ball is half
a diameter away from the other one you
know that's the phase difference well
then you have a dark band okay and
that's how they explained it and same
thing with here that I had oh no I don't
have ways because waves is the same
thing essentially what they're saying is
that the wave hits the slit and when
this wave hits something whatever it
hits it instantly collapses it's called
the wavefunction collapse what does that
mean it turns into a particle but in the
case of wave when they do this let
explain it with water they
the analogy is always with water they
said look what happens when water goes
through some kind of opening we'll call
it a slit yes you got a little opening
water goes through there will water tend
to open up and so when it hits the slit
whether whether it's got that little top
part in there or not they say well as
soon as it touches us that immediately
on the other side of the partition of
the slit it opens up and it goes in
every direction that's how they simulate
or that's how they explain and that's
how they model this thing and try to
convince you that the wave can go
inwards
in other words around the center of the
slit and it's cheating because you know
you can only get that effect as far as I
know the only way you can get that
effect is if it goes through a slit but
if you have the opening you know if you
just have a tree it tends to go outwards
but yeah it goes around I guess but
here's the point here the point that I'm
trying to make here is the fine here if
you have if you remove the edges of the
slit in other words this if you just
remove that part there that's
disappearing
well the particle should go straight and
so should are a wave you know if it's an
electromagnetic wave and goes in one
direction only it should just go
straight should not touch anything and
for some reason the wave goes around and
that's why they'd like to use water
waves because they say well you know on
the other side of the that tree that
you've got in the middle there the wave
does go around and goes inwards okay
with water waves you can probably
simulate that but the question is does
light behave as water waves is that a
fair analogy and I'm saying it's not but
let's continue here what's the
difference with a rope model well the
rope is a two-way mechanism as you can
see the Rope just rules in place it's
already stuck to the other end so it
doesn't leave
whatever origin it has it's stuck to
both ends it just twirls in place and so
the wave portion goes in both directions
and that's the advantage of the rope
model one guy can't remember who it was
says the wave arrives before it leaves
or arrives at the same time as it leaves
it it's just like you know that's the
description they try to give you how
light behaves and yeah that's that's
exactly what a rope does the Rope tours
in place so it's leaving and arriving at
the same time at both ends there should
be no no question about that
you know just twirls in place okay so
what do we have here we have the slit
model of the rope model of the slit and
that's that you know you have the ropes
already connected to the needle and to
the screen both okay and before you turn
the light on you know what you have is
simply there they're already tied
they're just at a frequency that our
eyes cannot pick up as soon as you turn
the light on you know you get the
fringes instantly almost you know for
for this before such short distance as
300,000 kilometers per second is quite
fast that's a torsion that's the speed
of the torsion so you know as soon as
you turn the light on it off limits for
us it's instantaneous but now we can
explain why because you know the ropes
are already connected they're there all
the highway is there they all you need
to run this car through the highway and
this car runs at 300,000 kilometers per
second 300,000 kilometers per second
that's almost the the distance from here
to the moon in one second and and it
does so for what a few meters that you
have in your room wherever you do the
experiment so it's it's instantaneous
for us so we need to turn the light on
you know now
the ropes start twirling at a higher
frequency and where you have rope meets
rope from once the side of the slip with
a went from the other side if they're in
phase you get a bright ban and whether
they're half a link you know away from
each other they're out of phase that's
where you get the dark band and you know
I didn't invent that by the way I only
got the rope model to do it but this is
this is what you see you can you know
they've been doing this with waves for a
long time what we're doing is replacing
the wave with a rope and we're saying
with the rope you know it makes sense is
the if assuming you know the pink one
there the pink thread it ends up in the
same position as the one coming from the
other side of the slit they're both in
phase then you know there's constructive
interference and when you don't have a
green one against the pink one well then
you're out of phase okay and that's when
you have destructive interference and I
explained that in a little more detail
not only in the presentation but also in
the paper that I'm finishing writing
here's the needle experiment which I
like to show because you know here you
have the needle okay you have a needle
and you shine a laser you know laser
pointer and you're saying you can do
this at home not a billion-dollar
experiment just put the needle like I
did at the presentation and you point
the needle let's see that was great name
okay anyways you can point this at a
wall whatever and you'll see that the
fringes you will see the fringes created
by the needle the laser pointer
monochromatic light by the way light of
a single frequency and single wavelength
and a needle okay yeah to do is just
point it at it at the wall and you'll
see what I want
you'll see the fringes and again this
experiment was done first by Newton by
the way and a lot of people were not
aware of that one guy who was aware of
it was Thomas Young Thomas Young 1801 he
does this experiment after reading
Newton's book optics and Newton covers
it in his book and he says he saw
shadows so Thomas Young repeated the
experiment he he was doing different
experience he did the double slit and
then he said oh I'm gonna try a Newton's
experiment he did so and he found the
fringes and he wrote about that that's
what I presented you know in Buenos
Aires and so I decided to I don't know
why that got stuck in history re
unburied it you know on earth it and
decided to do it myself and yes you can
see there you get the fringes those are
caused by the needle and so now we got a
problem because again as you can see
here where is it with a slit with the
particles you know if you put a needle
there the particles should just go
straight so you cannot explain this with
quantum remember quantum is a particle
theory they they insert the wave to save
theirs their hides or skins but really
the wave has no business in quantum
because quantum is a particle theory and
what they try to do is put the wave
whenever they can't explain something
with a particle and here you see it's
got nothing to bounce against so you
know if you can produce a fringe with
particles well you gotta explain how how
that how that happens you know you gotta
rationalize that and that's something
they can't do so you know with a needle
you can't do you can't do it with a wave
either but again they have the wave
going around and you know but here we
have a problem with that because look at
this here you have the this is a ripple
tank and the waves are coming from above
they're going through two slits there
and out the other end here's the de
single-slit okay and it's a very narrow
one here's a little wider slip but you
can see the waves at the bottom just go
outwards they don't interfere here they
interfere because you have two slits so
let's look at that one more time
if you have a single slit very narrow
single slit okay and you can see the the
wave is not interfering with anything it
just opens up it just fasts
fans outwards and here's the same thing
with a wider slid you can see that's
always going outwards
it's when two slits are there that one
wave interferes with the other one so
how do we explain this with the same
mechanism with particles you know you
can because with a single slit you know
the particles assuming when they went
through that little hole okay they would
open up okay they would just get wider
and wider and and and with the two slits
there you would have particles
interfering with particles but why would
they you know how do you explain this
huh how would you how do you explain the
mechanism with particles and they don't
what they do they explain it with water
waves and the questions again whether
like behaves like water waves and I
guess the answer for that question is no
it doesn't okay so that's essentially
what we discussed for the slit
experiment you've got to read the paper
you got a look at the video I'm going to
upload hopefully this week I'm working
on that right now and well and I'm sure
lots of people will have questions about
that okay how that's really done from
there we moved on to polarization the
third leg of the presentation or the
third presentation they were kind of
individual one was simply a prerequisite
to the other why is the slit in a
prerequisite to polarization because I
think that you do also have a little bit
of this phenomenon of this mechanism
inserted into polarization
again once you read the paper you'll see
how I put that in there but there's a
bigger mechanism as far as I'm concerned
with polarization let's start with what
it is polarization here we have
polarization okay you shine the light
I'll move aside a little bit here you
shine a light monochromatic light
well no I'm sorry you sound just that
you can sign in any light essentially as
far as I'm concerned you can say in any
light yeah and what happens is the
polarizing plate calques bar Iceland
calls coughs bar is famous for this
there they get their aries oriented and
in this case we have the aries for the
first polarizer vertically and for the
second polarizer their horizontal okay
and supposedly if we follow mr. crenell
he who came up with a bit offense
explanation here you can have it do
something like this let's seem to make
that a little bigger do something like
this the first polarizer allows the
vertical component of light and they
usually explain that by saying it's the
electric field okay and so you had
electric magnetic this is the electric
component and supposedly but goes after
that is just the electric component of
light so it's like light that's in
between these two polarizers the
vertical and the horizontal allegedly
consists only of electric of the
electric field there is no magnetic
field because that's what's stopped by
the first polarizer
allegedly but they'll say that you know
you have lights in in all these
different directions you know they don't
like to look at a single wave they would
like to show you that you know there's
many waves and so they chopped off the
electric from one and the magnetic from
another and they build a wave again I
guess on the other side I don't know
because if they're gonna chop just the
electric field are they saying that the
light between the two polarizers
consists of only electric field
if they chop off the magnetic field okay
but anyways the deal is that you have a
horizontal and a vertical component the
vertical polarizer does not allow the
horizontal component of light to go
through just the vertical ones and then
when you turn the other polarizer you
know here you have they're both like
this right see if I get it right
and then second one you turn horizontal
you have 90 degrees and what happens it
blocks the remaining vertical component
which is the one that made it through
and that's why you see no light on the
screen that's the explanation how does
that differ from what the rope model
proposes well the Rope model says that
instead of going through the holes the
interest this is the the spaces between
atoms the rope model says light goes to
the atom and through the atom light is
relayed from atom to atom not through
the holes not through the spaces between
atoms but from atom to atom because all
atoms are interconnected and so it's a
totally different mechanism so how do we
produce this effect well something
similar this is what I showed again a
million-dollar experiment here so treat
it very well let me get this out of way
so that you can see it better and go
something like this here you have light
and let's assume you got these ropes
okay
you see them there okay so we have the
ropes this way you have the ropes
straight ahead okay what happens when
you turn the second polarizer at 90
degrees well you're you get that
situation with the ropes okay now you
don't have them connected straight ahead
but you have them you know you go from
here to there
that's essentially the main mechanism
for why light is stuff it's not relayed
so what other questions came up and for
you to ponder ok so what happens when we
turn it one more time you
so now we have them like that right
again they're not straight ahead
but now we've we've got the beam back
again so what so when it was like that
we can all understand why light goes
straight ahead here we can say okay now
light is stopped fine so far so good
but when we turn it one more time well
we're not straight ahead so why does
light get reinstated why can we see
light again when we're a hundred and
eighty degrees from where we were here
zero degrees here's 90 degrees here's a
hundred and eighty degrees we have to
explain that and of course there is an
explanation and I can ask you is to read
the paper when I put it out there
I'm gonna put the video and a paper out
there there is an explanation and for
this you need to look at the molecules
okay you need to know what the structure
of the molecules are in the calcs bar
okay and no one's done that no one's
really done well they've done a little
bit of that but you know it's they just
described it they said well when the
molecule is like this light doesn't go
through no molecules like that it does
go through but they don't explain why
what's causing what the mechanism is and
I'm gonna work on a mechanism in the
papers so that's as far as I can give
you right now simple straightforward of
why you know the second polarizer stops
the light yeah that's just a stopgap
until you read the paper okay
I'll let you try to figure out I mean
obviously you wanna try to figure out in
your own brain how that could happen I
can only give you my version again I
don't hurt you to believe it I urge you
to understand it wholly and then
meanwhile you can work your own you know
mechanism see if you can come up with a
better mousetrap you know maybe you got
a better solution than I do keep in mind
one thing that's always important
also and I didn't get the the image but
you know when you know I gotta here hold
it you see I've got it here see I made
specifically I made a second plate here
okay and the issue is that when the
second polar the one in the middle right
if I insert a 45-degree angled polarizer
in the center in between the two plates
like this see here this one is 90
degrees
this one over here right - this one
right but the middle one as you can see
is 45 degrees okay
that's important to note and when you
put that 45-degree angled polarizer you
reestablish the beam more precisely as
you move that second polarizer between
these two polarized as you move them
gradually from zero to 45 you recreate
more and more and more of the beam so
it's a gradual appearance of the beam
it's not like you got to wait till you
get to 45 before you reestablish the
beam you're reestablishing the beam for
every angle you turn that second
polarizer here it is again okay so you
have the start out like that right just
look at the two outer ones right and if
if you just turned this one around that
way if you turn let me get that right if
you turn this one like that right then
you can see what's happening to the
ropes the question is why when you put a
second one a third polarizer between
them at 45 degree angle 45 degree angle
why does that re-establish the beam okay
and that's what we need to explain
that's what the papers are gonna be
explained okay anyways just thought I'd
give you a quick rundown of what we did
in Buenos Aires besides you eat and have
fun we
enjoy ourselves I think we had a good
discussion there where the folk that
went there and I can only urge you to
assist you know attend the next one if
we do that one in Sweden and some
questions will pop up you know how some
of these things the mechanism behind
these things hopefully we can address
those issues read the papers and watch
the videos and I'm also gonna make a
little real physics simulation of both
the slit and polarisers hopefully for
that you can see the mixin mechanisms
are should be straightforward easy
you should look and say okay I
understand the mechanism that's that's
how physics should be physics is for
kids yeah you don't need any math to
understand this stuff all you need to do
is visualize the mechanism say oh okay I
see how mother nature does this and if
the rope model has any validity we
should be able to do it that's simple
with with with some kind of rope model
you know where you use it you use the
rope as the mediator for light you
should be able to explain polarization
slit and the whole works you can't just
say well I explained this experiment and
you still cannot explain none of the
rest of course you know there's a lot of
stuff out there you know I can explain
magnetic attraction between two
rectangular magnets but then some people
say well how about levitation you know
put you've seen probably out there you
know this magnet floating seemingly in
midair because it's pushed up there by
another magnet and people say well how
does that well first let's understand
the simple stuff then we can always work
on the complex stuff and this is where
we run into trouble people first want to
jump into the one that's awesome the one
that really all comes see how is that
done well you know let's get simple for
it let's find out how simple when we're
then you can progress and say okay now I
know how this one works let's see if we
can apply that same mechanism to these
more complex situations okay folks
anyways once again we're gonna be having
these lectures Sundays and Wednesdays
two times a week give you ten to give
some feedback also give us time to catch
up on a lot of stuff that we got to do
and you know I've got once's my son he's
gonna be born Osiris a couple months
down there and he's probably gonna
participate here and there he's got a
lot of work to do doing some programming
stuff and so he he will be participating
on and off hopefully hopefully I get to
see him every now and then and you will
be able to hear him as well or at least
maybe they'll type something whenever
he's you know yeah
the lectures what else no I guess that's
it all I want to say is yeah those who
missed it well they they missed a lot of
fun that we had and I guess that was
worth it worth it to go down there and
discuss things with some of the folk and
eat and be merry and drink merry
we had some beer we had some good food
and good chats and hopefully we'll
repeat that next year if we do this in
Sweden okay with that I'm gonna see you
on Sunday and hopefully we can see each
other
what is it Sunday at 9 o'clock Frankford
time what else
guess that's it unless anyone has any
questions all I can interview is to read
the papers watch the videos and after
that you'll probably have even more
questions we'll see you on Sunday
see you then bye bye